Philip is in DC I fell up welcome to the
Dave Ramsey show hi Dave thanks so much
for taking my call it's really an honor
sure how can I help so basically two
years ago my mom convinced me to loan
her half of all my savings so seven
thousand dollars and spend it on Bitcoin
now two years later we haven't made any
money on that investment now sorry did
you give it to her to invest in Bitcoin
or we decided we were going to invest it
in Bitcoin
well she I loaned it to her okay you
invest and so she took the risk and she
borrowed the money from her son to take
the risk okay yeah so now I'm in college
and I need the money for tuition and so
I want her to give the money back to me
and she's now refusing and she's saying
bitcoins gonna make us into millionaires
in the long term and it would be a
totally foolish thing and she's
basically just stamping down and saying
she's not gonna give me back the money
because bitcoins gonna turn us into
millionaires and I pretty much this
money is pretty important for me just so
I can get through college debt-free and
I mean do you think that she's right Oh
Bernie at coin do you think I'm 20 okay
I'm a sophomore
no she's wrong and she's wrong and she's
wrong and she's wrong number one you
don't borrow money from your what at the
time 17 or 18 year old son if you're
that big a loser you don't need to be
investing number two when you do borrow
money from your own child and they ask
to pay it back because they're in
college you give them the money back you
don't be a loser number three you pick
the worst possible thing to invest in
you're gonna lose your but you're not
going to be a millionaire in Bitcoin
you're gonna be seven thousand dollars
poorer so mom's wrong like three times
three strikes you're out
tell her you want your money back and
you want it back now this is wrong well
what kind of person borrows money from
their kid to be in a shade
investment I mean under snow I'm sorry
not care I'm sorry I'm calling your
mother names I'm sorry but um okay but I
mean I'm just mad for you you're 20
years old you should be living your life
you shouldn't be worrying about these
kinds of things you should be working
about your studies and finishing your
degree you shouldn't have to be worried
about your own mother having taken money
to go off on some lark because no I mean
Bitcoin someday may turn into something
today you would have a better chance of
becoming a millionaire at the roulette
table in Vegas do you do you have any
suggestions for other things to invest
in or do you know I you know what I
would invest in I would invest in
Phillip finishing his degree I think
you're a better investment than anything
else I know about there I invest in real
estate mutual funds but I think you're a
better investment because I think your
degree what they're studying something
reasonable and that's marketable what
are you studying us I'm doing economics
and a minor in computer science tada
these are very marketable usable skills
in the marketplace particularly in
Washington DC so yeah you're gonna do
fine with that
you know in other words the amount of
money you're gonna make as a result of
finishing this degree is a lot more than
you would make on an investment do you
see what I'm saying you're a good
investment yeah and this is the best way
to spend money on you when you're 20 and
you're studying something like this it's
good in school and you pay cash for it
and you stay out of debt and you do all
those wonderful things I don't know how
to be how to suggest since your mother's
being belligerent that you just say mom
you know I talked to a financial coach
and he completely disagrees and I know
you and I don't agree with about this
but it is my money and I'm trying to
finish school and I really need you to
catch that out and give me my money back
today well I don't think you're right I
don't care if you think I'm right but I
mean her belligerence on this and her
desperation to become a millionaire with
a $7,000 investment I mean come on
really this is a golfing a bit
unrealistic yeah it isn't a bit on yeah
that's a good that's a nice way of
saying it yeah
so as you stood as you complete your
field of study in economics you'll see
the flaws in the Bitcoin thing Bitcoin
is it has a lot of wonderful attributes
to it and someday it may become a
stabilized currency but today currency
is based 100% on one thing trust I have
a bunch of military coins that guys that
have served in the military and gals
have served in the military when they
shake your hand they give you a coin
it's a sign of Honor and I love those
I've got up hundreds of them in my
office and right beside them I have a
dollar bill or an $18 bill or whatever
it is with a picture of Saddam Hussein
on it you know what that dollar bill is
worth zero because Saddam Hussein is
dead and he's not a dead president it's
a dead country that went away and had to
be completely reformed there's no trust
in that currency so I can't trade that
for anything but you take a green piece
of paper with a dead president on it
from the United States I can trade that
first off why because of trust Bitcoin
doesn't have that trust yet because all
it's got right now is a get-rich-quick
smell all over it and people are
avoiding it that are smart